vu ça cette image c'était en argentine à
la gare de l'indépendance
donc par grec grec anglais et français
c'est vrai tu dis moi j'ai envie de tout
bouffer le cuir
mais l onas efa autocollants auto
colossal
apparemment tu dis ça
je l'aï déjà dit mais moi alors c'est
vrai oui j'ai déjà dû dire ça dans ma
vie peut-être pas comme ça dans cet
ordre aux lames et à perth
colosse mais mois plus tôt c'est à cela
qu'il
regarde regarde cette image incroyable
qui nous vient de buenos aires s en
argentine sur cette vidéo une femme
tombent entre le train et le quai
heureusement elle s'en sort
miraculeusement à grâce à l'aide des
passagers elle s'en sort donc indemne et
a pu repartir en fauteuil roulant
malaise à le faire malaise malaise c'est
incroyable si on est sorti ce soit louis
voilà est-ce que vous vous êtes passé à
côté de vraiment vous avez un truc
vraiment vous vous êtes dit je passe à
côté de l'ama bah vous visiblement à la
chicha vous n'êtes pas que ça ça de la
mort
comme
celle où on est fier d'être sonné ouais
et voilà c'est comme ça et c'est ça
c'est de retour du bourg un justin mapp
et sa wii en plaindra pas non plus en
fait le unissez vous à moi comme la
femme qui est tombée serait en train un
jour il ya une femme qui est tombée sous
moi
j'étais en train de courir quand je sers
donald je suis tombé dessus et elle s'en
est sorti miraculeusement
l'équipe le plan les yeux qui m'avait
contacté à l'époque
patois
hugo est ce que toi tu as des
noms j'aimerais passer à côté de la mort
mais par contre quand je regarde ces
images me dis que le karma est quand
même vraiment fort là on peut que y
croire parce qu'à ça à ça elle passe pas
entre les deux wagons m haies et toute
la conte tout échange est dingue j'ai
donc c'est complètement dingue c'est
très choquant comme image de rien très
fan castaldi toile à moi j'étais avec
mon père en corse et on est vraiment
passé à sa maman non c'est vrai c'est
vraiment l'être un petit bateau avec un
moteur faisait un mât moteur une borne
est en fait la barre de la barre de
rappel a cassé et le bateau en fait
c'est retourner comme ça on était tous
les enfants luke c'est plaque est
complètement du et franchement on est
passé on aurait pu tous mourir et voilà
je suis là donc je peux à bord on a eu
très peur et il n'y a pas si longtemps
quand j'ai plongé will haven font à huy
encore en corse encore en corse j'ai 29
ans je
savais qu'elle aille à huy gillot sur
était quand même tétraplégique cinq
minutes one si quelqu'un ne va pas
sauter pour me remettre à la surface que
ma femme ne bougeait pas
mais tétanisés j'ai envie d'avoir une
terre
être sauvegardés vous plaît on en débat
c'est
la vrai moi j'aimerais beaucoup que
j'étais les eaux et la fin rêvez-vous
quatre fois alors c'est passé sous un
camion ah ouais j'ai failli être écrasé
par un bateau à marseille en embarquer
pour le château d'if i s'est fracassé
contre le cul je suis tombé et mon père
martyrs au dernier moment c'est l'achat
mais là encore grâce à la malléole mais
seule la malléole appris c'est un
miracle parce qu'il ya un ressac bon le
stade de furiani ça c'est plus
dramatique est la quatrième fois quand
on est tombé avec mes parents à ski de
fond pendant 100 mètres sur un plan
incliné et miraculeusement s'est arrêté
à ça du précipice tôt taraweeh j'ai un
bon karma
enfin cinquième fois
[Rires]
donc c'est comme dans l'émission je te
font croire qu'ils en
briques de foot mais vous daniel banon
fin juin vraiment un gros gros malaise
j'étais dans l'eau pas très loin mais à
royan et qu'il y avait deux
cas les pieds va j'avais de l'eau
jusqu'à ce que je vais jamais là où j'ai
papier donc j'avais quoi m ais je me
suis senti très mal je suis aussi moi
parce que si vous aviez pied ferme est
doté par ailleurs mais parce que là la
plage là bas elle est très très faible
il y avait deux maîtres nageurs ils
pouvaient pas ne pas me voir j'étais
tout seul dans l'eau bah ils sont pas
venus images j'ai fait ça m'est pas venu
là ils sont amis avec 7,9 en
lisant du monde j'apprécie cette de coin